Es wird höchste Zeit mal wieder nach Frankreich zu gucken und zu ihr Frage zu beantworten, was macht eigentlich die Ligue 1? Und diese Frage beantwortet uns David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 93. David, hallo hallo.
Hallo lieber Max.
Sehr schön, dass wir zwei mal wieder miteinander sprechen können. Es wird allerhöchste Zeit. Das letzte Mal haben wir nach dem neunten Spieltag über die Ligue 1 gesprochen. Und jetzt sind, ja gut, je nach Verein, zwischen 22 und 24 Spiele ja schon gespielt in der Liga. Da ist man nicht ganz so konsistent, aber es wird seine Gründe haben. Wir haben so viele Themen, dass ich darüber gar nicht mit dir sprechen wollen würde, sondern dass wir gleich in die Sendung reinstarten.
Wobei, ich muss gleich noch mal reingerätschen, wie ein fieser französischer Verteidiger. Du weißt, warum die so unterschiedliche Spieltage haben, bei den Vereinen.
Nee, ehrlich gesagt ist mir das jetzt nicht klar.
Das liegt an den Gelbwesten, an den Gilets Jaunes. Da sind ja im Herbst ganz, ganz viele Spiele ausgefallen, und zwar richtig böse zum Teil. Da hatten einige Vereine drei Spiele in Folge Ausfall und dann gab es ganz, ganz seltsame Verwicklungen jetzt im Januar, dass da Spiele nachgeholt wurden und dann Spiele nicht eingesetzt werden durften, weil sie vor der Winter-Transferphase offiziell noch nicht dazugehört haben zum Verein. Und es ist alles ganz, ganz, ganz großes Chaos. Es hat sich auch einige Vereine beschwert. Sie sind nicht sehr glücklich mit der ganzen Sache. Und Paris hat sich dann nochmal den kleinen Luxus erlaubt, nach Beginn der, also nach diesem vorgezogenen offiziellen Beginn der Rückrunde, noch mal kurz einen Trainingslager in Katar zu machen und solche Schwäße.
Ja, ja, genau, wo man dann gesehen hat, es waren eigentlich eher sponsorigen Aktivitäten und da gab es einige Diskussionen. Ja, sehr gut, dass du das nochmal eingeordnet hast. Ich dachte nämlich eigentlich, ich hatte jetzt gar nicht an nicht sportliche Gründe gedacht, ich dachte mir, ach, Pokalwettbewerb irgendwie ganz wild, da darf jeder aussetzen und das weiß bloß wieder der doofe Max nicht. Aber das ist ein trüftiger Grund.
Der Rasen in Nizza war gefroren.
Ja, dann geht natürlich nichts. Dann stehen die Fußballerbeine still. Aber wir müssen kurz noch beginnen mit einem weniger sportlichen Thema bzw. ein Randthema, das aber doch ja die Zeitungen und Internetportale beherrscht hat, nämlich den Tod von Emiliano Salah. Wir haben es schon im letzten Kurzpass zur Premier League besprochen, wie in der Premier League die Reaktionen darauf waren. Also ein junger Spieler, der von Nantes zu Cardiff City wechseln wollte und auf der Rückkehr von der Verabschiedung seiner Teamkollegen ist das Flugzeug, die kleine Maschine, vom Radar verschwunden. Und inzwischen haben wir Gewissheit, er und der Pilot haben diese Reise nicht überlebt. Wie ist denn dieses Thema in der Ligue 1 aufgenommen worden?
Sehr groß.
Und wäre dieser tragische Unfall nicht passiert, hätte ich dir jetzt bestimmt auch was erzählt darüber, was für ein großartiger Spielersalar ist und wie der den Durchbruch mit Nantes geschafft hat. Ganz unglaublich treffsicher auch. Also ganz wunderbare Rate an Toren, aber eben nicht nur das, sondern auch offenbar ein ganz sympathischer Mensch, sehr, sehr beliebt bei den Spielern, auch bei den Fans. Man ist ja Argentinier, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass er irgendwie aus Nantes und Umgebung stammen würde. Und trotzdem hatten die Fans das Gefühl, dass es einer von uns, der lebt für uns. Das war tatsächlich ein entsprechend großes Thema. Ich nehme natürlich schon an, diese mysteriösen Tode beschäftigen uns Menschen vermutlich auch immer noch ein bisschen mehr, weil man einfach immer so rätselt und all das. Aber es war ein großes Thema. Nantes hat zweimal große Gedenkveranstaltungen gemacht. Jetzt am letzten Spieltag sind sie alle in Schwarz aufgelaufen gegen Niem und hatten 2-0 geführt, haben sich dann 4-2 verabschieden müssen. Ich glaube auch, dass der Mannschaft ein ganz schöner Knacks geschehen ist.
Und ist das in Frankreich ein Thema? Ich habe das in der Premier League-Folge thematisiert und wurde dafür auch von einigen Hörern und Hörern kritisiert. Es gibt ja jetzt die erste offene Forderung von Nantes an Cardi City auf die erste Rate des Transfers. Ich habe das mit Marco Hagemann besprochen und wir waren uns eigentlich einig, dass man dieses Geld verlangt. Das kann ja ganz viele auf versicherungstechnische Gründe haben. Wir zwei, also Marco und ich, fanden einfach nur die Art und Weise, wie das rauskann, nämlich dass man das nicht kommuniziert hat, sondern dann Cardi City das dann an die Zeitungen weitergegeben hat. Das fanden wir etwas unglücklich, weil es einfach ein komisches Licht wirft auf NORD auch als Verein. Wurde das in der Ligue 1 thematisiert, dass da jetzt quasi diese monetäre Forderung dann so ein bisschen über dem Gedenken steht an den Spieler?
Naja, NORD ist ein kleiner Verein. Also, kurze Frage, ich weiß nicht, ob es so thematisiert wurde wie jetzt bei dir, wobei ich jetzt auch nicht alle Diskussionen in allen Radio- und Fernsehkanälen verfolge. Aber zum Hintergrund natürlich ist NORD ein kleiner Verein. Diese 17 Millionen sind natürlich schon nicht ganz unwichtig für so einen Verein. Und man muss dazu auch wissen, NORD wird auch geführt von einem Präsidenten, der ein recht spezieller Mann ist. Walde Makita. Ich hatte den schon mal ganz kurz in 390 erwähnt als Geschäftsmann, der unter anderem Potenzmitteln und sowas macht, wobei er eigentlich Augenoptiker ist. Es ist auch so einer, der gerne mal schnell Trainer rausschmeißt, der der Meinung ist, dass er ganz, ganz viel Ahnung von Fußball hat und viel mehr als seine Trainer. Das war auch einer der großen Geschichten dieses Jahr in NORD, dass er einen Trainer installiert hat, der schön Fußball spielen lassen sollte, der ihnen Spielkultur bereit bringt und dann als diese Anlaufschwierigkeiten logischerweise, wie es immer so ist, er nach wenigen Wochen einfach vor die Tür gesetzt hat. Insofern wundert mich das jetzt nicht ganz so sehr, dass da vielleicht von Vereinsseite da ein bisschen hemsenamtlich umgegangen wird. Es ist ja auch legitim.
Ich will nicht sagen, nur nachdem eben auch das Feedback kam von einigen Hörern, warum ich das zum Thema machen würde, wollte ich jetzt eben quasi die Frage stellen, wurde das in der League-A thematisiert? Das hört sich ja ehrlich gesagt nicht so an. Vielleicht ist das dann auch einfach ein völlig normaler Vorgang und man sollte ihn dann auch nicht höher hängen.
Aber an der Sache nochmal, ja es ist jetzt so ein bisschen schwierig, so einen tragischen Vorfall als Anlass zu nehmen, darauf dann noch weitere Sachen aufzubauen. Aber ich fand das ganz spannend, es wurde unglaublich berichtet über alles Mögliche, über den gesamten Transfer, wie der abgelaufen ist, es wurde der Agent, gab es große Artikel dazu. Und um vielleicht mal den Schritt weiterzugehen, jetzt von dem tragischen Fall zum ein bisschen sportlichen, was ich sehr interessant fand, war unter anderem, dass der Brief dieses Agenten veröffentlicht wurde, mit dem er Salah überredet hat, diesen Transfer zu machen. Salah wollte eigentlich erst mal gar nicht weg, der fühlte sich da ganz wohl. Und naja, man konnte an diesem Brief, das war ein schönes Dokument der Zeitgeschichte, wie man sieht, wie so Agenten vorgehen. Also er hat unter anderem gesagt, ja, also übrigens bildet ihr da nicht so viel drauf ein, dass jetzt auch andere Clubs an dir Interesse haben, das haben wir alles lanciert, so arbeiten wir. Damit treiben wir deinen Preis in die Höhe. Das fand ich durchaus bemerkenswert und ja, also natürlich, der Mann sagt halt selbst, naja, hätte ich mich hinter diesem Interesse ja nicht geklemmt, dann würde er ja noch leben. Mein Gott, also ja, es ist alles immer schwierig, es ist ein sehr schwieriges Gewässer, sehr schwierige Thematik um so was rum.
Aber natürlich mal interessant, dass man dann, weil dieser Transfer dann eben so seziert wurde, da man dann einen Einblick bekommt. Also die erste Überraschung für mich, es werden noch Briefe verschickt an junge Menschen, also Emiliano Salabaya, 28.
Vielleicht war es auch eine E-Mail, das kann ja durchaus sein.
Und die andere Erkenntnis, dann eben zu gucken, wie Spielerberater mit ihren Spielern umgehen, wie man da eben auch versucht, Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten. Das hat jetzt eben einfach mal einen Einblick gegeben, den es sonst nicht gab. Und wenn wir dann schon so ein bisschen den Bogen machen zu sportlichen Dingen. Nantes, die standen tatsächlich das letzte Mal, als wir gesprochen haben, sehr, sehr schlecht da. Damals waren die – und das ist aber jetzt auch schon ewig her – auf dem vorletzten Tabellenplatz hatten erst einmal gewonnen und dreimal unentschieden gespielt. Da hat sich die Lage etwas entspannt. Also man ist jetzt inzwischen auf Tabellenplatz 15 in dieser 20er-Liga und hat fünf Punkte Vorsprung auf Monaco, über die wir später auch noch sprechen müssen. Das heißt, sportlich ging es ja bergauf bei Nort.
Ja, zwischendurch ist es sogar besser. Die waren sogar mal auf Platz 10 zwischenzeitlich und das hatte tatsächlich – also es hatte mit Salah zu tun, es hat aber auch mit dem Trainerwechsel zu tun, den ich eben angesprochen habe. Auf Cardoso ist Halil Hursic gefolgt. Ein in Frankreich durchaus bekannter Mensch hat damals Lille ganz groß gecoacht, war dann glaube ich auch ganz kurz bei PSG, ist dann mehr oder weniger gescheitert, war dann Nationaltrainer in verschiedenen Ländern, unter anderem in Japan und ist ein…
Ach, das war doch der Trainer, der Japan noch zur WM geführt hat und dann aber zurückgetreten ist und dann gab es Ashiro Nikina – nein, ach mein, jetzt fällt mir der ausgerechnetere Name meines Lieblingstrainers der WM nicht ein – der kam dann mit und hatte nur zwei Vorbereitungsspiele vor der WM.
Genau, also ein in gewisser Weise auch ein ganz starkes Unikat. Man fragte sich am Anfang, Gottes Willen, wie kann das zusammen funktionieren, eben Kita und Halil Hulcic. Das sind beides durchaus Sturköpfe. Halil Hulcic hat auch so einen süß-osteuropäischen Akzent, so ein ganz knorriger Typ, war früher selbst Spieler bei Nantes. Er hat ganz wunderbare Zitate in der Vergangenheit gebracht. Er beschreibt dann, wie die Spieler total ausgebrannt waren und verdrossen waren, als er ankam. Er sagte, wenn ein Spieler zweimal sagt, geht schon, geht schon, dann weißt du, dass er lügt. Wenn er sagt, einmal geht schon, dann ist es ernst gemeint. Wenn er sagt, sa va, sa va, dann lügt er. Und ich habe die Leute beiseite genommen und gesagt, also ich hier, ich habe früher auch auf der Naheposition gespielt und einen Non-Stürmer mit weniger als 20 Toren pro Saison, das ist kein Stürmer. Und ich kann auch keine Spieler trainieren, die ich nicht mag. Ich war selbst ein großer Techniker, ich war einer der besten. Ich kann denen heute noch technische Feinheiten beibringen. Ich kann ihnen mit 90 Jahren noch was beibringen. Er ist wohlgemerkt mit 70 Jahren einer der ältesten Trainer der Liga.
Durchaus von sich überzeugt, ja?
Genau. Also ein Knorriger, man kann sagen auf seine Knorrige als sympathischer. Man kann auch, wenn man es anders sieht, sagen, vielleicht ein bisschen nerviger Mensch, aber ich mag ihn durchaus. Er hat ihn durchaus defensive Stabilität eingeimpft. Er hat das schöne Spielen etwas zurückgezogen. Sagt dann auch, naja, ich muss wohl Sadomasochist sein, dass ich mir das alles antue. Aber in Frankreich schreibt man das ja über jeden, der viel arbeitet, dass er Sadomasochist ist. In Japan arbeiten die Leute einfach.
Also er hat auf jeden Fall eine interessante Trainer, Vita mit Stationen in der Ligue 1, dann bei Trabzonspor, dann bei Etihad in Saudi-Arabien, die Elfenbeinküste, Dynamo Zagreb, Algerien, Trabzonspor, noch einmal und dann eben Japan, die übrigens natürlich inzwischen nicht mehr von Ashino Nikira trainiert werden, sondern von Haime Moriyasu. Wie konnte mir das entgehen?
Wie konnte dir das entgehen, Marcin?
Ja, wie konnte mir das entgehen? Da schreit es mal wieder nach einer neuen Sendung, aber das werde ich wann anders tun. Okay, also dann haben wir Nord mal so ein bisschen eingeordnet, auch sportlich. Dann gucken wir uns mal die Tabelle noch genauer an und wir müssen natürlich wieder bei PSG beginnen. Da hat sich etwas getan, nämlich die haben verloren. Wer hätte das gedacht? Jetzt eine Niederlage gegen Lyon, 2 zu 1, aber ansonsten läuft alles wunderbar und der Eindruck von außen ist, haben wir auch schon das letzte Mal drüber gesprochen, es zählt sowieso nur die Champions League und da drehen sich jetzt die Diskussionen vor allem um zwei Namen, nämlich Neymar, der definitiv ausfällt und Cavani, der eventuell für das Duell gegen Manchester United auch ausfallen könnte.
Ziemlich sicher. Ja, sie haben verloren gegen Lyon. Es war ein großartiges Spiel, muss ich sagen. Ich habe es live gesehen. Gerade die erste Halbzeit war absolut offenes Visier, wunderbare Chancen von beiden. Und ja, es ist so ein bisschen ein Fluch. Es ist so ein bisschen der Fluch der Champions League, weil sie hatten, das glaube ich, bislang in fast jedem Jahr, in der Vergangenheit hatten sie vor dem Achtelfinale irgendwelche größeren Ausfälle. Letztes Jahr auch schon Neymar. Ich glaube, zwei Jahre davor war es Thiago Motta. Der Slogan von Paris ist Paris est magique. Paris ist magisch. Irgendjemand schrieb die Tage, es handelt sich oft mal eher um Schwarzmagie. Gestern sagte jemand auf RMC, dem Radiosender, vielleicht verkrampft Paris viel zu sehr vor diesen großen Champions-League-Aufgaben. Die sollen sich mal ein bisschen locker machen. Manchester United ist jetzt auch kein Überhaus. Du merkst, dass die.
Nerven liegen. Der Stand zur Champions-League-Auslosung und der Stand bis jetzt ist gerade die einzige Mannschaft, die in der Premier League marschiert. Und Liverpool und City, da habe ich schon wohlwollend dann einige Unentschieden als noch marschieren durchgehen lassen.
Also das wird kein Selbstläufer, das ist auch brutal. Ein Nehmer, 5 Euro ins Phrasenschwein ersetzt du nicht so leicht, die Antritte waren unglaublich wichtig. Du merkst, dass bei Tuchel auch ein bisschen Nerven blank liegen. Der hat sich ein paar Mal jetzt Wutausbrüche gegen Schiedsrichter geleistet, ist jetzt sogar auf die Bank verbannt worden. Ich glaube, es war ein Pokalspiel.
Auf die Tribüne meinst du vermutlich.
Auf die Tribüne, ja. Er hat einen ganz großen Zoff mit seinem Sportdirektor, Henrique.
Hat sich vielleicht dafür gewünscht, dass es das nicht gab.
Genau. Also im Grunde haben sie nach Nahe für Vor das selbe Thema wie im Sommer auch. Es fehlt ihnen immer noch ein zentraler Mittelfeldspieler, vor allem ein abräumender Sechser. Tuchel versucht das jetzt zu deichseln, indem er Marquinhos nach vorne gezogen hat. Verratti war ja auch verletzt. Der wiederum könnte jetzt wieder fit sein für Manchester. Er spielte auch schon gegen Lyon. Ich fand ihn dann nicht sehr überzeugend. Du hast schon gemerkt, dass ihm da ein bisschen die Spritzigkeit gefehlt hat. Also der ist sicherlich auch nicht auf 100 Prozent. Und ansonsten muss man sich schon ein bisschen wundern, was die da als Transfers veranstaltet haben.
Also Leandro Paredes kam im Winter fürs Defensive Mittelfeld von Zenit St. Petersburg. Ende.
Genau. Und es wurden ganz viele andere Sachen angekündigt. Das waren ganz viele andere im Gespräch. Ein Acosta, ein Lyon. Und da wurde alles nichts draus und es gibt ja auch immer noch den Satz von Uli Hoeneß, dass er sagt, es sei ja peinlich, dass er sich damit Henrique hätte abgeben müssen. Was sagt das für eine Figur?
Ja gut, wenn Uli… ach nee. Machen wir einfach weiter.
Du meinst, er muss sich nicht über Sportdirektoren und anderen Vereinen lustig machen. Es ist offenbar ein Machtkampf im Hintergrund. Die haben beide ihre jeweiligen Kreise, ihre jeweiligen Zirkel aktiviert. Offenbar muss der Präsident Nasser al-Khalifi öfter mal als Mittler einspringen, was ich auch etwas seltsam finde. Also es brodelt hier im Hintergrund. Und diese ganze Affäre rund um Rabiot macht die Sache nicht besser.
Der eben immer noch suspendiert ist auf Wunsch des Vereins. Und Thomas Tuchel sagt, naja, ich respektiere dann schon den Wunsch. Die Situation hat sich nicht verändert zum November. Aber du hättest eben da diesen 23-jährigen zentralen Mittelfeldspieler, den man aus sportlichen Gründen ja gerne auf dem Feld sehen würde.
Genau, der sicherlich da was helfen könnte. Er hat auch seine Schwächen, aber ist definitiv ein starker Spieler. Er war viele viele Jahre lang in einer eigenen Jugend. Er ist definitiv ein Talent. Und ja, der Verein sagt eben auch gerade in Form von Henrique, naja, der Junge will seinen Vertrag nicht verlängern im Sommer. Deswegen setzen wir ihn auf die Tribüne. Kann man verstehen, dass da ein Trainer vielleicht sagt, hm, ist mir jetzt grad nicht so ganz recht. Wohlgemerkt, Tuchel hat möglicherweise dann nicht ganz unschuld, weil es gab im Herbst, das war kurz nachdem wir gesprochen haben, das letzte Mal gab es die Sache, dass er Rabiot und Mbappé auf die Bank verbannt hat, weil sie zu spät kamen. Weil sie damals den Klassiker schauen wollten noch im Fernsehen und dann zu spät zum Training kamen. Und Mbappé kam dann rein noch, hat das Tor noch gemacht, hat sich entschuldigt und alles war gut. Und Rabiot scheint das deutlich stärker angefasst zu haben und angefressen zu haben, dass er da so behandelt wurde. Also das mag durchaus auch ein Keim gewesen sein von dieser leichten Entfremdung. Man muss aber auch sagen, Rabiot war in den vergangenen Jahren schon immer durchaus selbstbewusster Mensch. So ist es nicht.
Aber ja, man merkt schon, auch wenn in der Liga natürlich alles wunderbar läuft für PSG, aber jetzt mit Blick auf das Champions League-Achtelfinale und eben auf diese Nebenthemen, da ist schon wieder die Temperatur gestiegen auf dem Kochtopf PSG, so wie eigentlich in den letzten Spielzeiten auch immer regelmäßig um diese Zeit.
Ja, weil darauf kommt es halt an, also daran wird das gemessen werden. Das ist das große Ziel, die Meisterschaft ist eindeutig durch. Sie wollen dieses Jahr unbedingt diese Champions League schaffen und die Tatsache, dass sie 47 Millionen für Parades ausgegeben haben, zeigt halt auch, dass ihnen offenbar dieser ganze Rummel um Financial Fair Play möglicherweise auch gerade egal ist, weil, oh, wir haben die Chance, also das war ja noch, das hat sich schon angebahnt, da waren ja immer noch fit, das war halt dieses, okay, wir haben die Chance, wir wollen das jetzt nutzen. Und mit dem Kopf durch die Wand und alles andere ist es gerade egal und na gut, dann sollen sie das nächste Jahr bestrafen oder vielleicht kann der Präsident ja noch irgendwas Deichseln im Nachhinein, das ist uns doch nicht bestrafen, wer weiß das schon. Aber das ist ihr Ziel, das ist ihr großes Ziel und darauf ist alles fokussiert.
Gut, dann gucken wir, wir können uns das ja ganz entspannt angucken, was da im Achtelfinale passiert und dann werden wir auch mitbekommen, wie Thomas Tuchel mit dieser ganzen Situation umgeht.
Dann ganz kurz nochmal vielleicht für die deutschen Hörer zumindest noch als Abschluss sagen, Thilo Kehra hat sich sehr gut eingeführt, spielt stark, spielt sehr konstant, kann sogar sein, dass er jetzt gegen United als Rechtsverteidiger aufläuft, weil ja ein Meunier auch verletzt ist und na gut, Shupo Mutting eher weniger. So, Lequip schrieb heute Morgen in einem Kommentar also um diesen berühmten 3 Buchstabensturm, den ja alle großen Vereine haben wollen. Um den 3 Buchstabensturm zu haben, müsste man neben Mbappé Shupo Mutting aufstellen, dann hättest du 3 Buchstaben, aber es wäre vermutlich keine gute Lösung.
Ok, danke noch für die Einordnung, dann wissen wir auch, wie wir das so ein bisschen verorten können. Hinter PSG hat sich auch nicht so wirklich viel getan im Vergleich zu unserer letzten Sendung, die ja schon eine ganze Weile zurücklegt. Lille und Lyon sind die beiden Verfolger, wobei das Verfolger in Anführungszeichen zu setzen ist, denn aktuell sind es bei zwei Spielen mehr, 10 Punkte Rückstand für Lille und wie gesagt, PSG könnte noch 6 Punkte noch da drauf addieren. Wie ist denn da die Situation?
Ja, wir waren ziemlich gut in der letzten Folge. Wir haben über ganz viele Vereine gesprochen, die nach wie vor da oben stehen. Lag natürlich nicht wirklich an uns, sondern eher an uns.
Nee, also erstmal lag es nicht an uns, sondern wenn dann an dir, weil ich gesagt habe, David, worüber möchtest du sprechen? So viel Zeit muss sein.
Ja, na gut, ich bin halt einfach die Tabelle von oben nach unten runtergegangen. Ja, geiles Konzept. Ja, genau. Wir hatten ja auch – kommen wir gleich nachher nochmal dazu – wir hatten ja auch recht die Kritik, dass wir immer safe vergessen haben oder nicht erwähnt haben. Das war nicht alles gut damals. Ja, Lille ist eine großartige Story im Grunde. Man muss da zur Einordnung nochmal sagen, dass die im März 2018 einen Platzsturm hatten von frustrierten Fans, die kreuzunglücklich waren mit dem Verein, der in finanziellen Schwierigkeiten steckte, der im Abstiegskampf steckte, wo gar nichts zusammenging. Und jetzt sehen sie gut genug aus, dass es ein Zweikampf um Platz 2 mit Lyon war. Ich glaube, im Mai haben sie ihr Duell gegeneinander. Das könnte richtig krachen, aber die haben sich beide ganz gut abgesetzt. Der aktuelle Trainer Galtier sagte auch, der Präsident hat mir die Situation damals beschrieben, als ich gekommen bin. Ich wollte das gar nicht richtig glauben und habe dann festgestellt, es war tatsächlich so schlimm, wie er es beschrieben hatte. Wir haben damals ja schon ziemlich ausführlich gesprochen über diese Offensivreihe, über den Roadrunner, über das BIP. Vielleicht können wir noch mal ganz kurz erwähnen, was auch gerade anfangs ein bisschen untergegangen ist, ist dieses unglaublich starke Mittelfeld aus Thiago Mendes und Shekka. Beides ganz, ganz wunderbare Spieler. Und wie wichtig die waren, konntest du unter anderem sehen beim Spiel gegen Reims. Ich glaube, das war der 17. Spieltag oder so. Da hat der Trainer von Monastar gesagt, wir haben bewusst die beiden aufs Spiel genommen. Wir haben die bewusst gedeckt. Und das war viel wichtiger, als die Angreifer zu decken. Und tatsächlich haben sie dann nur ein 1-1 geschafft. Also ein sehr überzeugendes Mittelfeld. Und dahinter nominell ist noch, der war eigentlich zu Saisonbeginn, hätte der eigentlich sogar auf Stammplatz 1 sein sollen, ist Thiago Maia. Das ist ein ganz junger Spieler, 20 Jahre alt, der auch, ich erinnere mich da, ein Spiel gegen Toulouse. Da hat er mit einem hohen Pass auf den Stürmer, also es war ein Pass, der würde allen Packing-Fetischisten feuchte Tröme machen. Hat alle überspielt, war ganz großartig. Und dieser Stürmer, auf den er gespielt hat, das war Leao, auch ein ganz spannender Kerl, 19 Jahre, Portugal, Angreifer, 188. Der, ja, also ich zitiere mal ein bisschen was, der wird von seinem Berater in Lille gesagt, man habe jetzt den portugiesischen Mbappé. Und von Sporting, wo er ausgebildet worden ist, wurde gesagt, es sei das größte Talent der Akademie unserer Geschichte. Und wohlgemerkt, in Sporting wurde ein gewisser Cristiano Ronaldo ausgebildet. So, und jetzt sind das natürlich viel zu viele Lobeshymnen für so eine zarten Schultern. Der trägt ihn mittlerweile ganz gut, man muss da auch nicht viel drauf geben auf solchen Lob, aber das ist ungefähr die Fallhöhe, auf der er aktuell steht. Und interessanterweise kommt er damit ganz gut zurecht. Er ist vergleichsweise ausgerechnet, er ist nur vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu verspielt und zu unbekümmert und könnte noch ein bisschen mehr Verantwortungsbewusstsein lernen. Dabei hat die Technik, die Schnelligkeit, die Physik…
Ja, vor allem ist er richtig jetzt ins Rollen gekommen, wenn man sich anguckt, dass er in den letzten sieben Spielen sechs Treffer und eine Vorlage gemacht hat. Es gab nur ein Spiel, in dem ihm keins von beiden gelang, also jeweils in jedem Spiel getroffen. Das zeigt, dass er sich ganz gut etabliert hat.
Genau, da hast du den Grund, warum Lille da oben steht. Sie haben eine dynamische Offensive, ein starkes Umschaltspiel, sie haben starke Verteidiger. Über die Verteidiger können wir dann im nächsten Spieltag ausführlich sprechen.
Du hast die Zeit sehr gut im Blick. Perfekt. So wünsche ich mir meine Gäste, David. Dann lass uns über Olympique Lyon sprechen. Die sind aktuell mit 6 Punkten hinter Lille auf dem dritten Tabellenplatz und haben auch 6 Punkte Vorsprung auf dem vierten Tabellenplatz. Also nach unten und nach oben. Aktuell stand 24. Spieltag für Lyon gerade nicht so viel in Bewegung. Ist man denn damit zufrieden?
Naja, man ist nicht zufrieden, dass Lille vor ihnen steht.
Das ist schon der Anspruch von Lyon, die Nummer 2 zu sein.
Ja. Also zumindest, wenn Marseille und Monaco da unten irgendwo rumdüppeln. Das wären vermutlich eher die nominellen Schwergewichte, mit denen man das Gefühl hat, dass man sich auseinandersetzen müsste. Muss man ja bei dieser Saison nicht. Lyon ist Licht und Schatten. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele von ihnen in der Champions League mitbekommen hast, aber das war so ein bisschen das Sinnbild. Da waren sie auch Licht und Schatten. Also sie können an großen Tagen – ich glaube, sie sind ungeschlagen gegen City, ne? Ein Unentschieden oder ein Sieg. Das ist das, was sie an großen Tagen schaffen können. Also sie können City bezwingen. Sie können aber auch genauso gut gnadenlos scheitern. Jetzt am Wochenende 0 zu 1 gegen Nizza, haben gegen Straßburg im Ligapokal 1 zu 2 verloren. Du hast Fick hier ein bisschen als Sinnbild davon. Der ist an großen Tagen, kann dir einen genialen Pass spielen und ist präsent und an manchen anderen Tagen taucht er einfach ab. Ich hatte, glaube ich, beim letzten Kurzpass vor allem dieses Mittelfeld gelobt. Diese ganz jungen Spieler um ein Dombele. Da ging auch gerade dieser Hype-Los um ein Dombele. Ich glaube, der war auch in der Nationalmannschaft angekommen. Der hatte eine Schwächephase, ebenso wie dieses andere Talent Toussaint. Die sind alle ein bisschen immer wieder untergetaucht. Du hast Depailles mit teilweise großartigen Leistungen. Dann taucht er auch wieder ab. Er hat auch ein bisschen dievenhafte Allüren. Er hat jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen noch mal bekräftigt. Er möchte ja gerne mal zu einem großen Club wechseln.
Das hört man sich ja gerne in Lio.
Genau, hört man als Fan unglaublich gerne.
Wie mache ich mich beliebt bei meinem Verein? Das kleine 101.
Insgesamt sind sie offensiv, defensiv stark. Defensiv haben sie immer wieder Schwächen und Aussetzer. Da gab es vor ein paar Monaten her, im Herbst, gab es einen spannenden Artikel, den ich gerne mal dir zur Diskussion stellen möchte oder zum Nachdenken für andere Vereine oder andere Kurzpässe, ob die Defensivsprecher von Lio am heutigen Ausbildungsrezept der Vereine liegt. Weil sobald ein Spieler gut ist in der Jugend, wird er tendenziell immer nach vorne gezogen. Ja, das habe ich auch schon mal mit jemandem darüber gesprochen. Und Lyon verletzt sich ja sehr stark auf seine Akademie. Die haben großartige Spieler rausgebracht, Fikir, Benzema, Ben Afa, Marcial. Aber wenn du jetzt an Denkwürde gefahren, Teiliger, denkst, fällt spontan nur jemand wie Umtiti ein. Die Frage wäre dann sozusagen, züchtet sich Lyon seine eigene starke Offensive und seine eigene schwache Defensive heran?
Ja, ein interessanter Punkt. Da kenne ich einige Leute in deutschen Nachwuchsleistungszentren, die das übrigens auch für den deutschen Fußball gelten lassen würden. Weil eben sobald du technisch beschlagen bist, wirst du auf die 6 gestellt, weil das die Position ist, auf der du am schnellsten deine Entscheidung treffen musst im Jugendfußball. Und wenn du ein sehr schneller Spieler bist, dann wirst du auf den Flügel gestellt, weil Geschwindigkeit da ein wichtiges Konzept ist. Und gleichzeitig habe ich auch schon mit Leuten gesprochen, die mir gesagt haben, wenn man sich dann auch anguckt, was die Innenverteidiger und Außenverteidiger lernen in Nachwuchsleistungszentren, dann hat das ganz viel mit Passspiel und mit Dribblings und so weiter zu tun und sehr wenig mit Zweikampfführung. Und einer hat da sogar mal zu mir gesagt, die können alles bloß nicht verteidigen.
Also ich bin echt gespannt, was sie gegen Barca zeigen. Bin ich wirklich gespannt. Wenn sie gut drauf sind, könnten das großartige Spiele werden, wenn nicht eher nicht.
Ich meine, sie haben eine wahnwitzige Champions League gespielt. Das muss man schon sagen. Ein Sieg gegen Manchester City im allerersten Spiel und dann nur noch unentschieden. 2 zu 2, 3 zu 3, 2 zu 2, 2 zu 2, 1 zu 1 gegen eben Hoffenheim, Schachtel, Donetsk und dann nochmal gegen City. Und so kommst du dann ins Achtelfinale gegen Barcelona. Also ich will jetzt nicht schlecht reden. Es ist ja auch eine Leistung, gegen all diese Teams immer zwei Tore zu schießen. Aber es zeigt eben auch schon sehr deutlich in die Richtung, die du ja gerade eingeladen hast, wackelige Defensive. Es ist halt auch doof, dann gegen all diese Mannschaften dann genauso viele Tore zu kassieren. Manchester City würde ich da mit rausnehmen.
Ja, es war zum Haare rauf. Sie haben zum Teil auch eine Mannschaft dominiert und sich dann noch Tore einschenken lassen. Ein Spieler, auf den man vielleicht in Zukunft noch ein bisschen achten kann, ist Ferland Rondy, Außenverteidiger, 23. Auch eine ganz spannende Person, kommt immer recht unbekümmert drüber. Er hat auch selbst gesagt, ja, war ich als Kind schon immer so. Führt halt dazu, dass er mal sehr riskant verteidigt und auch sehr eher versucht, sich spielen zu befreien, als jetzt das Technik zu setzen oder mal den Ball wegzuschlagen. Und er hat mal im Interview gesagt, ja, er hat mir immer wieder gesagt, dafür bezahle ich mal. Ich habe bislang noch nicht dafür bezahlt, also mache ich jetzt mal so weiter. Und der hatte bis, weiß nicht, 12 Jahre bei PSG gespielt. Und die haben ihm nach, also in der Jugend, haben über Verletzung gesagt, also Profifußball, können er sich abschreiben, wollte er aber nicht. Also ist er gewechselt und hat dann zwei Jahre unter Schmerzen gespielt, bis die Schmerzen weg waren. Und hat den Ärzten davon nichts erzählt, weil er war halt 14 und wollte sich umweg durchbeißen. Und die Ärzte in Lyon müssen dann komplett fassungslos gewesen sein, dass er mit einer Arthritis in der Hüfte irgendwie Profi geworden ist. Also, ja, sehr spannender Kerl.
Ja, definitiv interessante Lebensgeschichte. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde. Andererseits soll ja jeder seine eigene Entscheidung für seinen eigenen Körper treffen. Wir sollten es uns vielleicht nicht als Vorbild nehmen. Das ist der einzige Grund, warum ich es mit dem Profi-Fußball nicht nochmal probiere.
Quatsch, liebe Rasenfunk-Hörer da draußen, nehmt es euch nicht als Vorbild.
Nehmt es euch nicht als Vorbild. Wir haben hinter PSG, Lille und Lyon eine ganze Verlangsanvereine, die sich in einem sehr engen Punktekorridor bewegen. Montpellet, Marseille, Saint-Etienne und Nizza haben 37 Punkte. Rennes 36 Punkte. Und Strasbourg und Rennes haben 35 Punkte. Das heißt, von... Rennes, ja, ja, ja, genau. Fürchterlich. Max. Also, von Platz 10 bis Platz 4 sind es tatsächlich nur drei Pünktchen, die sich da die Vereine... Also der Unterschied sind zwei Punkte zwischen den Vereinen. Lass uns kurz mal diese Vereine durchgehen und bei Marseille einen längeren Stopp machen, denn da gab's ja die – du hast es ja angesprochen – berechtigte Kritik, dass wir die das letzte Mal ausgespart haben und meine Güte, was ist da alles passiert? Aber erst mal kurz ein Wörtchen zu Montpellier, die aktuell stand heute da mit einem Spiel weniger die Verlangs anführen auf Platz 4 und damit auch die besten Chancen haben, sich so ein bisschen zu distanzieren da noch und den vierten Platz zu sichern.
Ja, also du musst bei all den Vereinen, glaube ich, sagen, musst du vorwegschieben, hätten wir uns jetzt vor zwei Wochen getroffen oder vor drei Wochen oder vor vier Wochen hätte da jeweils jemand anders die Form der Woche gehabt. Die wechseln sich tatsächlich bunt ab und lassen auf starke Formen dann wieder schwache Formen folgen.
Grad Montpellier ist da mit vier Unentschieden und einem Sieg aus den letzten fünf Spielen vielleicht das perfekte Beispiel.
Genau, genau, genau, genau. Die standen ja, als wir letztes Mal gesprochen hatten, sogar unter den Top 3. Die sind da ein bisschen runtergefallen. Sind aber trotzdem doch wirklich ein spannendes Team. Hoher läuferischer Aufstand, sehr fluides Spiel auch. Also außenverheiriger Flügel wechseln häufiger ab. Oder Lötter Leck, eher Sechser, taucht plötzlich ganz weit vorne auf. Wir hatten letztes Mal, glaube ich, stark über die Defensive gesprochen.
Ja, genau, weil damals hatte es sehr wenige Gegentreffer.
Hatte ich Delors und Labort schon erwähnt? Ich glaube nicht, ne? Nein. Das sind die beiden Spieler von Montpellier. Die sollte man dringend auf jeden Fall nochmal kurz erwähnen. Die beiden Spieler, die beiden Stürmer von Montpellier. Das ist der Grund, warum sie Herbst und Anfang Winter da ganz oben standen und da oben mitmischen. Die Sturmentdeckung der Saison. Delors ist jemand, der mehr jagt und presst. Laborte ist jemand, der mehr in die Zwischenräume läuft. Aber beide sind unglaublich laufstark. Beide geben Sätze von sich. Du musst halbtodseitige Krämpfe haben. Das gehört dazu, wenn du aus dem Spiel rausgehst. Delors ist 27, Laborte ist 24. Der Spielmacher dahinter, Molay, ist 26. Das sind keine jungen Talente, sondern ein guter Fußballer. Delors kommt auch aus der Region.
Sie sind aber sehr abhängig von den beiden. Die beiden haben 18 der 31 Treffer gemacht. Also jeweils 9 die beiden. Dahinter, wie du gerade angesprochen hast, 3 Tore. Dann noch Ouyangou mit 2. Dann kommen nur noch Einzeltor-Schützen. Man ist auch abhängig davon, dass die 2 ihre Tore machen. Genau.
Wobei sie gleichzeitig noch einen unglaublich starken LeConte im Tor haben. Es gab jetzt zum Januar ein paar spannende Statistiken zum Kalenderjahr 2018. Was ja auch mal eine interessante Sichtweise auf Dinge ist. Nicht mehr immer so per Saison. Und LeConte hatte 0, 9 Tore pro Spiel im Kalenderjahr 2018. Also weniger als 1 Tor pro Spiel. Das ist durchaus ein Wert.
Absolut. Sie haben ja jetzt auch erst 19 Gegentreffer. Man erkennt, warum wir damals viel über die Defensive gesprochen haben bei Montpellier.
Genau. Wobei sie zuletzt einige Spiele hatten mit relativ vielen Toren. Das unentschließende gegen Monaco 2 zu 2. Gegen Nîmes haben sie ein Tor kassiert.
Also es könnte sich da gerade wieder ein bisschen was verändern bei Montpellier. Okay. Aber dann haben wir da ja mal eine neue Perspektive aufgemacht. Dann aktuell hinter Montpellier auf Platz 5 eben Olympique Marseille, mit denen wir uns eben mal kurz ein bisschen länger beschäftigen müssen. Denn da ist viel passiert. Was man vielleicht hier mitbekommen hat, war, dass es einen Böllerwurf gab. In einer Partie gegen Lille nach 12 Minuten nach der Pause explodierte ein Böller direkt vor den Prüffüßen von zwei Olympique Marseille-Profis. Und das Spiel wurde eben kurzzeitig unterbrochen. Und seitdem, bis zur Aufklärung dieses Vorfalls, spielt Marseille vor Zuschauerzahlen wie 71. So was im letzten Spiel notiert, wo man tatsächlich mal wieder gewinnen konnte gegen Girondir Bordeaux.
Ist ja auch zweimal gewonnen sogar jetzt in Folge. Gegen Dijon und gegen Bordeaux. Deswegen sind sie auch gerade wieder im Aufwind. Deswegen stehen sie auch da oben. Wir rechnen die sechs Punkte weg und dann hast du die Krise. Auch da konnte ich meine – ich hab immer wieder so ein bisschen Notizen gemacht, Notizen geskribbelt. Weil könnte ja mal sein, dass der Max anruft. Da hätte ich dir noch irgendwie eine Statistik erzählen können, dass sie jetzt in der Tabelle seit Spieltag X aktuell auf Platz 18 stehen oder so. Und in der Formtabelle ganz weit hinten. Und plötzlich, zack, sind sie da oben auf sechs. Also ja, ähm, ja, äh, also tatsächlich der Grund, warum ich über Marseille nicht gesprochen hatte. Und das sage ich jetzt einmal bewusst, war, dass sie schon damals nicht besonders gut gespielt haben, aber trotzdem relativ weit oben war. Und ich dachte irgendwie so, na ja, ich kann da nicht so viel, das kann ich gar nicht sagen. Natürlich ist es nach wie vor der größte Club Frankreichs mit der größten Historie. Ich habe übrigens auch den von dir empfohlenen Trikot-Austausch-Podcast gehört, unter anderem die Folge über die Ligue 1, und da haben sie auch Marcel nicht erwähnt, habe ich sofort gesagt, Mensch, wie kann man nur?
Ich hoffe, ich habe einen Zuhunten-YouTube-Kommentar geschrieben.
So macht man das heutzutage.
Aber das kann man ja auch noch ganz gut einordnen für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war ja auch die Zeit, wo man bei Marcel zum Beispiel in der Europa League schon deutlich gesehen hat, nicht zuletzt im Duell mit Eintracht Frankfurt, dass da noch nicht alles zusammengeht. Aber in der Tabelle hatte es sich noch nicht niedergeschlagen. Die waren, als wir das letzte Mal gesprochen hatten, noch dritter, aber schon mit viel Action vorne und hinten. Also 21 Treffer hatten die damals noch neun Spieltagen erzielt, aber auch 16 kassiert. Also da ging sehr viel bei Marseille und das wackelte aber ganz schön bedenklich und ist ja dann auch zusammengebrochen.
Also Sie haben nach wie vor das Problem, Sie hatten bis vor kurzem keinen Stürmer und Sie haben keine gute Verteidigung. Und gleichzeitig haben Sie im Transfersommer Unmengen an Geld ausgegeben, also 28 Millionen für Strothmann, 19 Millionen für Charlie Tata, 14 Millionen für Radonjic. Also Strothmann ist der Einzige, der in der Stammelf steht, wo man aber selbst wieder sagen könnte, naja, hätte es das wirklich gebraucht. Lopez und Sansan sind eigentlich ein ganz wunderbares Mittelfeld. Also am Mittelfeld hapert es jetzt bei Marseille nicht gerade. Wo es halt hapert, ist der Sturm. Da stand mit Mitroglu eine der seltsamsten Transfer-Verirrungen der letzten Jahre vorne drin. Also wirklich ein Totalausfall. Dann mit Valère Germain, einen Stürmer, den ich persönlich sehr, sehr mag, der sich auch sehr reinhängt, aber das ist ein eher altruistischer Offensivstürmer. Das ist keiner der, das ist kein Knipser. Und insofern sind die Fans zu Recht auch seit Wochen sehr, sehr unzufrieden. Marseille gehört ja jetzt mittlerweile Frank McCord, dem amerikanischen Investor, der da das Champions-Projekt ausgerufen hat und gesagt hat, er will investieren, er will da Marseille wieder zur alter Größe führen. Und die Mannschaft gibt das aktuell nicht her. Naja, gab das aktuell nicht her, wie gesagt, zwei Siege jetzt und eben große Änderung bei Lottelli. Lottelli wollten sie schon im Sommer haben, haben ihn damals nicht bekommen von Nizza. Er hat jetzt eine Grottensaison, Grottenhindrunde für Nizza gespielt. Jetzt haben sie ihn. Aber tatsächlich scheint er gerade bei Marseille ein bisschen aufzublühen. Mal schauen, ob das so weitergeht. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass Garcia als Trainer sich gerade ein bisschen entzaubert. Er galt immer auch an einigen Kreisen als großer Taktiker, als Tüftler, als Umsteller. Das ist vielen Fans, so wie ich es mitbekomme, gerade auch etwas zu viel. Er stellt viel zu viel um. Gefühlt ist keine Mannschaft wie dieselbe des Vortags. Er macht Aktionen, wie dass er eben Gustavo ins Mittelfeld zieht und Paillette oder Torvain müssen falsche Neuen spielen, weil er eben keinen Stürmer hat. Und solche Sachen. Also es grummelt sehr. Die Fans sind sehr unzufrieden.
Ich habe gelesen, dass bei Twitter, bei den Kollegen vom Gutsport Podcast, wo ich hoffe, dass sie noch Kollegen sind und irgendwann mal wieder podcasten, ein kleiner Wink mit dem Zaunfallen, an der Stelle, dass bei der Partie Marseille gegen Monaco ab der 75. Minute laute Partymusik eingespielt wurde, um die Pfiffe der Heimfans gegen die eigene Mannschaft zu übertun. Das finde ich a, skurril und b, stelle ich mir die Frage, was bedeutet denn laute Partymusik?
Das weiß ich nicht, ich habe das Spiel nicht hier.
Es sei dir an der Stelle verziehen. Aber das zeigt ja schon, wie sehr es da grummelt. Glaubst du denn, dass Marseille, da musst du jetzt ein bisschen in den spekulativen Bereich, aber wir haben ja die Probleme jetzt genannt. Dazu kommt ja eben auch das Ausscheiden in der Europa League. Der Vorteil aber jetzt damit, jetzt kann sich Marseille auf die Liga konzentrieren. Jetzt hat man zumindest kurzzeitig einen Stürmer mit Mario Balotelli, der jetzt zwei Tore gemacht hat in, ich glaube, vier Partien für Marseille. Man kann sich auf die Liga konzentrieren. Siehst du da Anzeichen dafür, dass sich die Lage beruhigt? Oder wird das so weitergehen? Du musst dich jetzt aus dem Fenster lehnen leider.
Ja, ich muss immer vom Fenster lehnen. Ich bin skeptisch. Ich bin skeptisch, weil ich immer noch nicht genau weiß, ob dieses ganze Konstrukt zusammenhält und nach wie vor die Verteidigung ist nicht so wirklich da. Ich hab übrigens gerade plötzlich blödsinn geredet. Gustavo wurde nicht ins Mittelfeld gezogen, sondern er musste Verteidigung spielen, weil es keine Innenverteidigung gab. Du hast als schönes Beispiel in der Verteidigung einen jungen Kamara, der wirklich gute Ansätze hat, der ein spannender Spieler werden könnte, aber der auch beim Spiel gegen PSG gezeigt hat, dass er sich dann doch von einem MVP hat vernaschen lassen. Wohlgemerkt, das Spiel gegen Paris war ein richtig gutes von Marseille. Da haben sie richtig aufgedreht. Das war halt auch der große Klassik. Wobei die alten Fans im Vorfeld noch mal schön die Breitzeite rausgehauen haben. Sie haben gesagt, das Spiel gegen Paris war doch früher kein besonderes Spiel. Unsere Spiele waren gegen Nantes, Saint-Étienne und Bordeaux. Aber doch nicht gegen Paris. Wer ist denn schon in Paris? Also das ist auch die…
Klar, logisch.
So sieht sich Marseille auch zu Recht noch mit dieser Geschichte. Im Gegensatz zu diesen Emporkömmlingen aus Katar. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das trägt. Ich traue Balotelli noch nicht so ganz, weil das, was er in Nizza gezeigt hat, war echt ernüchternd. Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass Garcia teilweise ratlos ist. Er hat alles schon durchprobiert. Er hat mal den Good Cop geschildert, hat mal den Bad Cop gespielt, hat mal Spieler draußen gelassen, hat mal seine alten Leute bestraft und hat das wieder reingenommen. Also ich bin gespannt.
Man hört deutliche Zweifel. Es ist ja auch wirklich eine fürchterliche Saison für Marseille. Ich habe noch mal gerade nachgeguckt, weil ich mich an keinen Sieg in der Europa League erinnern könnte. Es gab auch keinen. Die haben tatsächlich fünfmal verloren und einmal unentschieden gespielt gegen Limassol 2 zu 2. Ansonsten alle Spiele verloren. Also auch das Rückspiel gegen Limassol. Da konnte ich mich noch erinnern. Das war ein Heimspiel 1 zu 3. Gegen Lazio, gegen Eintracht alles verloren. Also eine fürchterliche Europa League-Saison. In beiden Pokalwettbewerben sofort raus gegen Straßburg im Coupe de la Ligue, im Elfmeterschießen und im Coupe de France gegen André Zieu. Das ist wahrscheinlich kein Geiger, sondern ein Unterklassiker-Verein vermute ich.
Ein sehr unterklassiger Verein, ja.
Also eine sehr, sehr wilde Saison bei Olympique. Jetzt haben wir eben noch aktuell den Zuschauerausschluss. Also ich glaube, über Marseille werden wir noch weiter sprechen müssen, auch wenn wir später nochmal aufnehmen in dieser Saison. Okay, dann lass uns aber jetzt an der Stelle dann mal weitergehen und noch weitere der genannten Vereine kurz ansprechen, bevor wir dann auch noch auf Monaco blicken wollen. Saint Etienne mit Neven Subotich. Die hängen da auch mit drin in dieser Falanx aus Vereinen. Und die alle kabeln sich ja um einen Europa League-Platz. Das muss man sich an der Stelle noch mal vor Augen führen. Wie ist da die Situation?
Ja, ich kann kurz noch mal vorausstecken, ich habe den Tipp von dir aufgegriffen, habe mir das Interview mit Subotich angehört.
Bei Aufe Ohren?
Bei Aufe Ohren war echt klasse. Kann ich tatsächlich auch jetzt nochmal nur weiterempfehlen. Fand es auch sehr spannend, was über die Ligue 1 gesagt hat. Unter anderem, wie er beschreibt, dass es in der Ligue 1 noch sehr, sehr üblich sei, dass starke, physische, schnelle, dynamische Stürmer auf dich zubrettern und du da als verteidigende Lösung finden musst. Im Gegensatz eben zu vielleicht der Bundesliga, wo es ein bisschen mehr auf das taktische, mannschaftliche Gefüge ankommt. Das ist natürlich auch so eine zweischneidige Betrachtung.
Schöner, würde ich einfach sagen.
Ja, man kann es ja auch positiv sehen, es gibt durchaus tatsächlich sehr gute und physische und starke Stürmer in der Liga. Aber du hast natürlich recht.
Nee, ich meinte, das ist der Bundesliga. So habe ich es verstanden.
Ich habe es auch als Kritik daran gesehen, dass Frankreich vielleicht taktisch noch nicht ganz so weit ist wie die Bundesliga, mannschaftstaktisch. Das ist durchaus auch etwas, was man gelegentlich mitbekommt. Dass da vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr Fokus auf Einzelspieler gelegt wird, gerade in der Offensive. Defensive wohl eher weniger, aber in der Offensive, dass da schon noch ein bisschen Fokus auf Einzelspieler gelegt wird. Ja, Sanjay Tien hat eine gute Saison. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es angesprochen hatte, aber am Anfang der Saison war die Frage, ob Kasri und Cabella miteinander harmonieren. Das klappt ziemlich gut miteinander.
Kasri hat schon zwölf Tore gemacht.
Ja, genau. Sie hatten einen ganz spannenden Spieler, der jetzt eigentlich nach China gewechselt ist, von dem ich gar nicht genau weiß, wie man ihn... Selnaes ist ein Norweger im Mittelfeld. Den haben sie jetzt aber auch relativ umsichtig und smooth und ruhig durch Alpe Nacer ersetzt von Monaco, was ich auch gar keine so schlechte Idee finde. Sie haben ein relativ flügelstarkes Spiel. Sie sind bei sehr vielen ihrer Tore außenverwaltiger oder außenverkehr beteiligt. Also wohlgemerkt bei den Toren, nicht bei den Flanken. Flanken, Max.
Danke für diesen Hinweis.
Und das sieht sich alles ganz gut an. Gasset ist nach wie vor eine Autoritätsperson. Ich habe auch mittlerweile das Gefühl, dass sein Co-Trainer relativ stark taktisch involviert ist. Ja, aber gleichzeitig ist halt wieder – also die letzten 5, 6 Spiele waren eher wieder schlechter.
Ja, klar, das haben wir ja schon thematisiert. Also das bezieht sich jetzt eigentlich auf alle Mannschaften, über die wir jetzt gerade sprechen. Der Grund, dass sie so eng beieinander liegen, liegt daran, weil keiner von denen es geschafft hat, eine längere Serie zu starten an Siegen, sondern die alle mischen da immer wieder unentschieden Niederlagen mit rein. Es ist – ich will nicht sagen Schneckenrennen, das wäre zu viel – aber keiner hat eine konstant positive, gute Leistung und kann sich deswegen absetzen.
Sie haben jetzt am Wochenende ziemlich deutlich gegen Rennen verloren, die umgekehrt wieder so eine Mannschaft der Stunde sind, die vorher lange Zeit rumgedümpelt haben, aber sich jetzt gefunden zu haben scheinen.
Dann lass mal kurz über Rennen sprechen und danach müssen wir noch Nitzer kurz abhandeln, wenigstens. Was kann man über Rennen sagen? Die haben sich dadurch jetzt wieder ein bisschen rangerobbt, jetzt zwei Siege in Folge, vorher aber natürlich auch wieder unentschiedene Niederlage, so wie bei allen diesen Teams, die da drin hängen. Unter welchem Charakteristikum kann ich mir Rennen einordnen?
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe gar nicht so viele Rennen geschaut, weil sie tatsächlich so ein bisschen am Rumdümpeln waren. Rennen ist seit Jahren immer ein Verein, der eigentlich ganz klug einkauft, wo du immer vor der Saison das Gefühl hast, dass sie diesmal wirklich oben angreifen könnten und es dann oft doch nicht schaffen. Sie haben Ben Affa eingegliedert, mittlerweile recht gut. Das ist sehr spannend. Sie haben eine ganz interessante Kadertiefe. Es gibt dann so Außenwärtiger wie Zefane, der eigentlich Backup ist, der dann plötzlich ganz solide gute Spiele macht. Das spannende an Rennen ist eigentlich der Trainer aktuell. Das ist Julien Steffan, mit 38 Jahren sehr jung für Ligue 1. Wir haben da tendenziell doch noch eher ältere Trainer. Das ist der Sohn des Co-Nationaltrainers, Guy Steffan. Er hat zuvor Amateure trainiert in der dritten oder vierten Liga, ist seit 2012 bei Rennen, kommt eher aus dem Amateurbereich. 48 Stunden nachdem er wusste, dass er Trainer wird, musste er direkt gegen Lyon ran. Er hat dann gewonnen und hat danach gesagt, was das Drumherum angeht, das war schon alles sehr anders. Als bei den Amateuren meinte er, auf dem Platz ist halt ein Fußballspiel. Der Vorteil ist, ich kann jetzt Videoanalysen machen. Er sagt, er mag den spanischen Fußball, er mag Intensität, Ballbesitz, Umschaltspiel, aber Ballbesitz darf kein La Puala sein, darf nicht einfach Schnödelkunst sein, da muss man bei Ballbesitz auch was anfangen können. Ich finde das alles sehr, sehr spannend und sehr interessant, was er sagt, und ich bin sehr gespannt auf die weitere Entwicklung von der Mannschaft und auch von ihm.
Okay, und was können wir uns dann noch zu Nizza merken, die ja auch in diesem 37er-Punkte-Paket mit drin sind?
Ja, Nizza gibt es einen ganz, ganz großen Umbruch, weil der Präsident und der Sportdirektor gehen. Die haben sich zerstritten mit den...
Und da gehen sie beide. Geht da nicht in der Regel nur eine?
Nein, die haben sich zerstritten mit den Investoren. Ach so. Mit den chinesisch-amerikanischen Investoren. Da ist so ein Konsortium aus verschiedenen Leuten über die Transfers unter anderem. Man muss dazu wissen, der Präsident Rivière ist jemand, der eigentlich für diesen Aufschwung von Nizza im letzten Jahrzehnt verantwortlich ist. Das war derjenige, der Puel geholt hat als Trainer, der Favre geholt hat als Trainer, der Spielkultur etabliert hat, der Talente herausgebracht hat. Nizza war in den letzten Jahren eine ganz starke Quell von Talenten, aber eben auch immer wieder dann doch noch gespickt mit gestandenen Leuten. Du hast einen Dante nach wie vor der Rippen. Du hast eben dieses Wagnis Ballotelli eingegangen, das ja zeitweise auch sehr gut gegangen ist. Und das ist den Investoren aktuell zu viel. Nizza wollte wieder ein paar gestandene Leute haben. Und die Investoren haben gesagt, nein, machen wir nicht, geben wir kein Geld aus. Die scheinen ziemlich stark auf Rendite getrimmt. Die wollen Talente verkaufen, die wollen den Clubwert steigern.
Sie sind halt Investoren, um es kurz zu machen. Sie sind keine WIP-Haber, sondern sie sind Investoren.
Du hast aktuell ein sehr junges Team. Ich habe mal rausgesucht, unter den 11 Spielern mit den meisten Spielminuten, also alles über 1000 Spielminuten, sind sechs Leute 24 Jahre oder jünger. Zahar, Hassan Maxima, Cypria, Atal, Maulida.
Das ist der jüngste Kader der Liga tatsächlich.
Und ja, klar, das merkst du natürlich dann auch teilweise. Du hast mit Viera ein ganz spannendes Trainerexperiment an der Seitenlinie. Ein sehr sympathischer Kerl, der erstaunlich offen kommuniziert über sich und seine Gefühle. Er gilt als eigentlich eher leise und freundlich. Ich mag das Wort freundlich nicht, meine Aufgabe ist ja nicht unfreundlich zu sein, meine Aufgabe ist klar und gerecht zu sein, auch wenn ich bei Mario Balotelli manchmal Lust habe, ihn an die Wand zu knallen. Er hat sich offen mit Balotelli ziemlich gezofft und hat das aber auch offen kommuniziert. Er sagt, dass er ihn aufregt, aber gleichzeitig sagt er, ich kann ja auch keinen Spieler nicht aufstellen, weil er mich nervt. Da gab es ein paar durchaus interessante Einblicke in die Kabine. Aber er scheint das ziemlich gut zu managen. Im Gegensatz zu seinem Arsenal-Companion Henri, der ist gerade zumindest erfolgreich, was auffällig ist bei Nizza gerade, ich weiß nicht, wenn du mal kurz den Blick bitte richtest, auf die geschossenen Tore.
Ja, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Nizza hat 37 Punkte mit 19 geschossenen Toren. Und ich meine gelesen zu haben, dass das ein historischer Liga-Rekord ist.
Man möchte hoffen, dass das historisch ist, denn das ist schon sehr, sehr wenig. Da könnte man jetzt auch einfach das Klischee auspacken, naja, wenn der dein Trainer ist, und der sich mit Balotelli deinem Knips erzofft, dann steht die Defensive aber vorne.
Genau, er behauptet immer, dass er das schöne Spiel von Favre fortsetzen möchte, aber natürlich muss erstmal Defensive stehen. Sie haben ganz, ganz viele Spiele mit 1-0 gewonnen. Es ist auch nicht so ganz klar, wo sie gerade hingehen als Verein.
Gut, wie könnte das denn sein, in der Situation?
Genau, wollte ich gerade sagen. Diese Verwacklung im Hintergrund machen das noch mal schwieriger. Der Präsident hat jetzt schon angekündigt, er würde gerne den Club jetzt einfach direkt zurückkaufen. Also er geht jetzt und übernimmt dann quasi als Investor. Die aktuellen Investoren wollen aber oft mal nicht verkaufen.
Ja, das sind halt die Themen in einer Liga ohne 50 plus 1. Man kann es wirklich, auch wenn es vielleicht manchen schon zu den Ohren rauskommt, aber man kann das nicht oft genug wiederholen. Genau so sieht der Fußball aus, wenn Investoren im Fußball drin sind. Das muss nicht nur schlecht sein, aber so ist es dann eben einfach. Und dann redet man eben viel über solche Themen und nicht mehr über andere Dinge. Das ist quasi auch nur ein Videobeweis mit einem anderen Thema. Sprich, man führt halt ein neues Thema ein, über das dann die ganze Zeit geredet wird. Okay, jetzt müssen wir aber noch kurz über Monaco sprechen, denn da hat sich einiges getan bzw. auch irgendwie nicht. Denn das letzte Mal, als wir gesprochen haben, standen die auf dem Relegationsplatz, auf dem 18. Tabellenplatz. Und jetzt, wo wir sprechen, stehen sie wieder auf diesem 18. Tabellenplatz und haben die unangenehme Situation, dass die beiden Mannschaften hinter ihnen ein Spiel weniger haben. Und zumindest kein hat nur mit einem Punkt Rückstand da noch die Möglichkeit, dran vorbeizuziehen. Und wir hatten ein kurzes Gastspiel vorhin, viel der Name Thierry Ory schon. Hol uns kurz rein. Wir erinnern uns Thierry Ory als Praktikant im belgischen Nationalteam bei der WM. Wurde viel drüber berichtet. Und jetzt ein sehr kurzes Gastspiel bei Monaco. Warum war es so kurz?
Ja, und auch da, wir waren beim letzten Kurzpass spot-on. Ich glaube, ich hatte nämlich noch erwähnt, dass das Shadim auf der Kippe steht. Kann das sein? Dann haben noch Leute gesagt, boah, der Rasenfunk ist immer so aktuell. Ich hab's gerade gehört und schon ist es passiert.
Das war ein Lucky Shot. Ganz ehrlich, der Rasenfunk ist selten aktuell.
Ja, es ist ein unglaublich Transferwechsel-Chaos-Desaster gewesen, das sich da geleistet haben, aus dem alle ein bisschen beschädigt rausgegangen sind, muss ich sagen. Thierry Haurie hatte lange Zeit in Frankreich ein bisschen ramponiertes Image. Das lag zum Teil an ihm. Er ist ein verschlossener Kerl. Er ist jemand, der auch ein bisschen hochnesig rüberkommt. Er ist ein wandeles Fußballlexikon. Es wird kolportiert, dass er sich in Arsenal unterhalten konnte über damals was zwischen Duisburg und Bochum in der 2. Liga am Wochenende passiert ist. Er hat durch den Trainerposten in Belgien auf den Radar gerückt. Er hat auch früher in Monaco gespielt. Das klang alles ganz wunderbar. Er hat es aber eben nicht geschafft, diese Mannschaft von Jadim weiterzuentwickeln. Vielleicht lag es dann eben auch gar nicht an Jadim, sondern es lag dann eben auch an dieser Mannschaft, die auch ähnlich wie Marseille ganz fürchterlich zusammengekauft ist mit einigen Transfersflops. Für einen Barreker hat man 11 Millionen bezahlt und ihn nicht eingesetzt. Du hattest in der Hinserie ganz viele junge Spieler, wo du immer sagtest, da blitzt das Talent auf. Aber dann haben sie sich auch Patzer geleistet. Du hast plötzlich ganz starke Ausfälle gehabt von Leuten, die in den zwei Vor-Saisons noch richtige Bänke waren, wie Glick und Jemerson in der Innenverteidigung, wo du dich dann gefragt hast, vielleicht war die gar nie so gut. Vielleicht lag es dann doch eben an einem Fabinho vorne dran, dass die Innenverteidigung so gut aussah. Du warst im Tor zu Basic, der jetzt auch wirklich über sein Zenit drüber ist. Du hattest dann halt noch solche Sachen wie das Henri, das ist kolportiert, der wollte Falcao Tipps geben, wie er besser die Schusstechnik anwenden sollte. Und Falcao hat das nicht gotiert. Im Gegensatz zu, wie wir vorhin gehört haben, Halil Hozic, der seinen Stürmern sagt, wie sie sich zu behalten haben, hat das – und der es vielleicht auch kann, weil er dann eben die Autorität ist – hat das Ori eben nicht geschafft, diese Autorität aus Parkett zu bringen. Er war immer irgendwie ein bisschen eher Spieler als Trainer. Er hat auch bei Pressekonferenzen herumgemeckert über dieses und jenes. Und das heißt dann eben, dass Monaco tatsächlich schon angefangen hat, wieder mit Jadim Verhandlungen zu führen, dass Jadim sogar schon Transferverhandlungen geführt hat, als Ori noch im Amt war.
Also sprich, man hat den alten Trainer dann wieder zurückgeholt, nachdem der neue Trainer in 20 Pflichtspielen hat er 4 Siege geholt nur. Und da sind schon so Dinge dabei, wie im Viertelfinale des einen Pokals 9 zu 8 gegen Rennes. Das dürfte im Elfmeterschießen gewesen sein, ohne dass ich das jetzt näher nachgeguckt habe. Und in der ersten Runde des anderen Pokals mit 1 zu 0. Also sehr, sehr wenig Erfolg. Aber wie kommst du denn dann zu dieser bezaren Situation, dass man den alten Trainer zurückholt?
Weil der alte Trainer eben noch vor Ort war und immer wieder signalisiert hat… Also, Jadim ist kein schlechter Trainer. Jadim ist der Meistertrainer von Monaco. Er ist sicherlich auch ein… Ich halte auch nach wie vor große Stücke auf ihn. Er ist sicherlich auch ein großer Taktiker. Man kann ja auch durchaus sagen, dass die Entlassung tatsächlich zu früh war und dass es eben nicht an ihm lag, sondern dass es an diesem Kader lag. Es ist natürlich insgesamt eine blamabel Situation und es hat noch eine finanzielle Auswirkung. Dieses Trenderkarussell wird Monaco geschätzte 16 bis 20 Millionen Euro gekostet haben. Weil natürlich, als Jadim entlassen wurde, der hatte noch Vertrag bis 2021, der hat eine Entschädigung bekommen von 10 Millionen oder so. Und als Aurie jetzt wieder entlassen wurde, der hatte auch Vertrag bis… Ich weiß nicht wie lange, der hat auch noch mal 8 Millionen Entschädigungen bekommen und dafür noch der gesamte Stuff von Co-Trainer und so weiter. Aurie hatte gerade kurz vorher mit Passi einen Co-Trainer installiert bekommen, weil man sagt, na, vielleicht braucht Aurie einen erfahrenen Trainer nebenan. Also da wurden reihenweise zweimal Leute ausgetauscht.
Ich meine, da muss man jetzt keinen Mitleid haben mit Monaco, dem Verein, der Mbappé, Lemar und Fabinho verkauft hat. Die werden jetzt nicht am Hungertuch nagen, aber es ist natürlich eine interessante Randnotiz und zeigt, wohin es einen führen kann.
Naja, es ist zumindest Geld, dass man auch irgendwie in den Kader stecken könnte stattdessen. Man muss nicht Mitleid haben mit dem Club in Monaco, aber man kann durchaus Mitleid haben mit den Fans, die sich natürlich schon veralbert fühlen. Es gibt eine sehr, sehr kleine, aber durchaus auch spannende Fan- und Ultraszene in Monaco, die da auch so einen gewissen Nationalstolz haben, die sich eben auch als echte Monegassen sehen. Also man ist sehr, sehr verärgert über diesen Verein, über diesen Vorstand. Es ist ja auch in der Zwischenzeit diese ganze Sache passiert. Rübo Loeffleff war ja in die Affäre rund um die Football-Leaks verwickelt, dass er monogassische Polizisten bestochen haben sollen. Der eigentliche Vizier, der agierende Vizier, Vasiliev, da taucht er auf, dass er Mr. 10% genannt wird, weil er bei jedem Transfer immer noch abkassiert. Also das wirft gerade keinen sehr schönes Licht auf die ganze Sache. Wie du gerade gesagt hast, Themen, über die man sich unterhalten muss, wenn man Sponsoren und Besitzer mit drin hat. Was man aktuell sagen kann, ist, sie haben offenbar jetzt tatsächlich die richtigen Schlüsse gezogen. Was sie gerade eingekauft haben, wirkt alles sehr, sehr solide. Fabrikas haben sie geholt, sie haben Gelsen Martins geholt, einen sehr, sehr spannenden jungen Offensivspieler aus Portugal, der, glaube ich, an fünf von sechs Toren von Monaco jetzt seit er da als beteiligt war. Sie haben Baloturre geholt, einen der Baustelle der starken Lille-Abwehr, auch sicherlich ein smarter Transfer.
Naldo natürlich.
Golovin scheint endlich seine Form zu finden. Wir erinnern uns noch der große Stürmerstar von Russland aus der WM, wo man sich dann in der Hinrunde auch wieder fragte, naja, ist das so ein Sternchen gewesen, das bei der WM kurz aufflackert und dann ein trauriges Dasein fristet. Der hat zumindest jetzt wieder gezeigt, was er bei der WM drauf hatte und Lopez ist zurück. Der hat Monaco bitter gefehlt. Man muss auch sagen, sie hatten verdammt viele Verletzungen. Das darf man nicht außer Acht lassen. Sie haben ein unglaublich großes Tazarett gehabt. Sie haben zwischenzeitlich – im Dezember hieß es mal, sie haben 62 Spieler unter Profivertrag. Und jemand witzelte dann auf Social Media, ob sie da die Zuschauer mit eingerechnet haben in Monaco. Also, ja, Jadim hat Jemerson nach vorne gezogen aus der Innenverteidigung, wo er schlecht war. Der spielt jetzt mehr im Mittelfeld. Da scheint es ihm auch ganz gut zu gehen. Daran merkst du auch schon wieder, Jadim ist jemand, der sich gute Dinge auch überlegen kann. Was er schlecht macht, ist, dass er nicht jemand scheint, der wirklich so stark auf die eigene Jugend setzt. Sie hatten mit Badia Schiel einen ganz spannenden Torwart, den man einfach mal hätte auch reinwerfen können da auch. Den haben sie jetzt verliehen. Oder sogar verkauft, ich glaube, verliehen. Und sein Bruder Badia Schiel, der spielt in der Innenverteidigung. Also, nicht wundern, wenn plötzlich irgendwie auf dem Bogen Badia Schiel auftaucht und man denkt, warum spielt der Torwart in der Innenverteidigung? Nein, das sind zwei Brüder.
Also, es verliehen an Rennen.
Genau, verliehen an Rennen, ja. Wird das vielleicht auch nicht so gutiert haben? Also, darum murrt es auch wieder so ein bisschen.
Ich meine, wenn Fabregas sich holt, um da das Ruder rumzureißen, er zeigt ja schon, auf die Jugend setzt man jetzt nicht. Mir ist auch aufgefallen, dass Benjamin Henrichs, der ja zu Monaco gewechselt ist von Leverkusen, seitdem je gendant auf der Trainerbank sitzt, nicht mehr im Kader steht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da… Also, ich konnte jetzt nichts zu einer Verletzung finden. Wird der einfach leistungstechnisch nicht berücksichtigt?
Er war ja als Außenverteidiger geholt worden, hat lange Zeit immer ein bisschen weiter vorne gespielt, weil da Not am Mann war. Da hat er sich aber dann teilweise auch nicht so wohlgefühlt. Kann sein, dass er auch durch diese ganzen Umstellungen ein bisschen unter die Räder gekommen ist.
Also, es sieht zumindest aktuell so aus, weil es steht nichts von einer Verletzung irgendwo in den Quellen, die man dazu zitieren kann. Er hat links Verteidiger, linkes Mittelfeld, rechts außen hat er gespielt und rechts Verteidiger hat er gespielt. Und sogar am Schluss gegen die Jores nochmal zentrales Mittelfeld. Also, er wurde fröhlich rumgeschoben, da, wo Not am Mann war. Und aktuell zumindest sieht es jetzt aus nach zwei Partien in der Liga unter Jean Dain. Da war er beides Mal nicht im Kader. Das zeigt ja auch – mir fiel das jetzt eben auf – bei dem Punkt, den du gemacht hast, mit Ersatz nicht gerade auf die Jugend. Da haben wir ja Beweisstück B.
Ja, also gut, du hast Balotoré jetzt definitiv einen guten Linksverteidiger. Du hast halt immer noch einen CDB auf rechts, den ich da nicht mehr einsetzen würde. Das ist ja auch einer aus der großartigen Meistermannschaft. Ich finde ihn aktuell auch komplett außer Form. Aber ansonsten fügt sich da gerade eine Elf zusammen, die, wie wohlgemerkt, vor dem Wintertransfer zur Hälfte so nicht existiert hat. Also wenn du da draufschaust, wie gesagt, Martins Fabrigas Ballo Touré, dann ist noch der Vincenius gekommen, Silver ist noch gekommen. Die bauen da ganz stark um. Aber sie sind nach wie vor kein Verein für einen Abstieg. Sie haben da an Konkurrenz einiges gegen sich, die einfach die schwächeren Spieler haben. Das sind Sätze, mit denen schon ganz viele Mannschaften abgestiegen sind. Wir sind auf dem Papier keine Mannschaft für einen Abstieg. Aber ich kann es mir aktuell nicht vorstellen.
Wir werden es weiter beobachten. David, was schätzt du, wie lange wir jetzt gesprochen haben über die Liga? Könnte es sein, dass wir die Stundenmarke doch gerissen haben?
Nein, nein, nein!
Und zwar deutlich, mein Lieber. Aber ich wollte dir dann auch nicht immer dazwischengrätschen. Man merkt es ja, dass du hier voll bepackt mit Informationen, wie du in dieser Sendung gekommen bist. Wir sind jetzt deutlich über eine Stunde gelandet. Deswegen möchte ich an der Stelle in aller Höflichkeit dir ganz herzlich dafür danken, dass du dir so viel Zeit genommen hast. David Frogier de Ponlevoy, das hört 93, folgt ihm auf Twitter. Da heißt er n'gungongvn, wird auch wie immer verlinkt auf rasenfunk.de. David, vielen Dank, dass du dir immer wieder Zeit genommen hast.
Noch eine Minute lang, weil du eine wunderschöne Idee gehabt hast bei deinem Podcast zu den Podcast Awards und so weiter, dass man nach jedem Podcast noch kurz Werbung macht für einen anderen Podcast. Ja, sehr gut. Hat nichts mit Fußball zu tun, aber weil du gerade meinen Twitter-Namen erwähnt hast, der ja vietnamesisch ist, es gibt einen ganz wunderbaren, schönen kleinen Podcast, der heißt Rise and Shine, wird gemacht von zwei deutsch-vietnamesischen Journalisten, die ein bisschen reden über vietnamesisches und asiatisches Leben in Deutschland. Ist sozusagen eine Gruppe an Menschen, an Einwanderern, die man sonst nicht so auf dem Schirm hat. Sehr, sehr schön gemacht, kann man sich sehr gut anhören.
Werde ich sehr gerne verlinken, Rise and Shine, und zwar Rise wie der Reis, nicht wie das Auferstehen. Das wusste ich gerade beim schnellen Googeln herausfinden.
Der Wortspiel Max hat es kapiert.
Lieber David, vielen Dank für deine Zeit. Wir werden auf jeden Fall noch mal über die Liga 1 sprechen, irgendwann später im Verlauf dieser Rückrunde. Bin gespannt, was sich da in der Hand hat. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für die Aufmerksamkeit. Es wird noch einen weiteren Kurzpass in dieser Woche geben. Thema verrate ich an der Stelle noch nicht. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch eine Schlusskonferenz nach dem nächsten Bundesligaspieltag. Habt eine gute Zeit, bis bald, ciao.